[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti io lavoro in
un posto meraviglioso lavoro in una
fabbrica e con me lavorano altri 600
operai e fanno tutti dei lavori
meravigliosi siamo dei lavoratori della
conoscenza quelli che gli inglesi
chiamano knowledge workers tutti i
giorni mettiamo insieme quello che
sappiamo quello che conosciamo quello
che sappiamo fare e costruiamo tutti
insieme dei pezzettini di futuro ho
portato come questo oggetto che è una
scatola di metallo con degli inserti di
vetro l'appoggio qua e dopo vi racconto
perché l'ho portata per chi è in fondo è
questo oggetto qua
fatemi fare un passo indietro nel tempo
un passo di 125 anni
siamo nel 1893 tanto per dar
per darvi un'idea siamo nel periodo in
cui viene costituita la prima squadra di
calcio del campionato italiano
il genoa oppure ancora in cui esce il
primo numero della gazzetta dello sport
che allora si chiamava la gazzetta dello
sport il ciclista e la tripletta
oppure ancora quando viene prodotta la
prima targa automobilistica italiana
milano 1 oppure in francia i fratelli
lumiere inventavano e brevetta vano il
cinematografo
siamo in un periodo di grandi speranze
di grande fermento di grandi attese sta
finendo un secolo ne sta iniziando un
altro e le grandi speranze le grandi
attese sono in ambito intellettuali in
ambito culturale in ambito
imprenditoriale anche ed è il momento
proprio in quegli anni in cui un giovane
milanese di buona famiglia borghese
decide di intraprendere un'attività
decide di creare una fabbrica una
fabbrica tessile
un cotonificio per la precisione in
quegli anni considerate che l'industria
tessile era un po come l'industria delle
startup oggi quindi un un'industria con
un grande potenziale di sviluppo con
grandi attese di guadagno e anche con
tanta innovazione all'interno e il
nostro imprenditore il nostro giovane
imprenditore era anche un imprenditore
molto innovativo molto illuminato si
chiamava francesco somaini decide di
costruire la sua fabbrica dove in un
paese apparentemente insignificante tra
milano e como che si chiama lomazzo
perché proprio lì perché in quegli anni
da poco era stata terminata una delle
prime linee ferroviarie italiane la
prima sapete è stata la napoli portici
poco dopo ha seguito questa linea milano
como ed era una linea ferroviaria che
portava verso la svizzera verso l'europa
quindi portava con sé anche i germi di
un internazionalizzazione di una voglia
di crescere da un punto di vista anche
turistico e anche imprenditoriale quindi
anche da un punto di vista di trasporto
di merci e lo fa in quel luogo in
maniera innovativa perché in
controtendenza con quelle che erano le
abitudini del di costruire le fabbriche
allora perché in quegli anni le
fabbriche si costruivano vicino a dei
corsi d'acqua perchè l'acqua era in
grado di produrre l'energia che metteva
in moto le macchine i telai in questo
caso e francesco somaini decide invece
di costruirla vicino alla ferrovia era
tornato da poco da un viaggio in
inghilterra aveva visto nelle fabbriche
l'utilizzo del vapore e quindi decise
che anche nella sua fabbrica doveva
esserci il vapore a muovere le macchine
quindi non più l'acqua perché riteneva
che fosse più importante essere vicini a
una linea ferroviaria quindi vicini al
mo al punto è al momento in cui
arrivavano le materie prime da lì
potevano partire le merci a lomazzo
c'era una fermata di questa linea
ferroviaria
accanto alla fabbrica costruisce il
villaggio operaio costruisce il convitto
per le operaie che arrivavano da lontano
costruisce le scuole per i figli degli
operai
la stalla per essere autosufficiente
anche da un punto di vista alimentare
quindi di fatto un imprenditore che
aveva ben preciso un ruolo sociale nel
giro di pochi anni la fabbrica è in
grado di attirare circa un migliaio di
lavoratori diventa una fabbrica
importante una fabbrica tra le
manifatture più importanti d'italia e si
sviluppa in maniera esponenziale nel
corso di dieci dei decenni successivi
fino a che arriva la grande crisi del
tessile degli anni settanta portata
dalla concorrenza dei paesi in via di
sviluppo primo tra tutti l'egitto ma
anche l'india e la fabbrica di francesco
somaini prima comincia ad andare un po
meno bene e poi è costretta a chiudere e
chiudiamo anche la parentesi temporale
torniamo ai giorni nostri
nel 2008 la camera di commercio di como
decide che è arrivato il momento di
portare sul territorio un luogo capace
di attirare innovazione per poi metterla
a fattor comune e restituire al
territorio alle imprese e alle aziende
che stanno sul territorio e quindi
coinvolge in questo progetto altri
soggetti altri enti come per esempio la
fondazione cariplo un gruppo di banche
tutte le associazioni di categoria e
cominciano a cercare il luogo che
potesse essere opportuno e idoneo per
costruire un nuovo centro un nuovo parco
scientifico arrivano lomazzo vedono la
vecchia fabbrica ormai in in degrado di
somaini ed è amore a prima vista
acquistano la fabbrica la fanno
rinascere in due anni la fabbrica apre
di nuovo i battenti come parco
scientifico parco scientifico
tecnologico oggi digital innovation hub
comonext e questo è la fabbrica dove io
con altre circa 650 persone tutti i
giorni
lavoro del luogo fantastico di cui vi
dicevo prima bene qui dentro ci sono
oltre 120 aziende tutte sono aziende
innovative
ci sono start up ci sono aziende più
mature sono tutte aziende in cui
l'innovazione costituisce il germe e il
fattor comune rispetto a tutti quelli
che sono i knowledge workers che stanno
qua dentro
abbiamo aziende che costruiscono
satelliti spazzini che vanno nello
spazio e sono in grado di ripulire lo
spazio dai detriti dei vecchi satelliti
che sono ormai in disuso e potrebbero
essere pericolosi per i nuovi satelliti
che vengono lanciati ci sono aziende che
lavorano con le nanotecnologie le micro
e le nanoparticelle e costruiscono delle
finestre virtuali che sono in grado di
portare alla luce naturale del sole
sotto terra con obiettivi e scopi
terapeutici o anche solo estetici
abbiamo aziende che micro filano la
proteina nobile della seta all'albo in a
e ne fanno un tessuto che è in grado di
far attecchire le cellule del corpo
umano e viene utilizzato nella chirurgia
rigenerativa o ancora delle aziende che
lavorano con la grafite producono il
grafene con che è la plastica del dl del
nuovo millennio con un processo
interamente fisico e non chimico quindi
molto sostenibile anche da un punto di
vista ambientale
abbiamo lì la principale fabbrica di
grafene del mondo che produce 40
tonnellate di polvere di grafene
all'anno ma potrei andare avanti ancora
tanto perché le aziende sono 120 e le
cose che fanno sono davvero tutte
fantastiche e allora ho provato a
cercare di capire se ci fosse qualcosa
che fosse in grado di legare questi
imprenditori questi innovatori tra di
loro se ci fosse un denominatore comune
a tutti loro è quello che ho scoperto
essere effettivamente la passione per
l'innovazione la passione per andare
sempre un po oltre per guardare che cosa
c'è dietro l'angolo per non fermarsi mai
a quella che è la soluzione
apparentemente più facile più comoda e
questo è davvero trasversale a tutti è
quasi un pallino di tutti loro è
certamente la passione di solito siamo
abituati ad associarla qualcosa di
istintivo qualcosa di sé motivo di
emozionale più al sentimento che alla
ragione e andando però a scavare e
andando a chiacchierare con tutti loro
quello che emerge che nel caso della
passione per l'innovazione cessi un
primo momento istintivo un primo momento
legato all'intuizione e quindi alla
scintilla il primo motore immobile ma
subito dopo c'è la subentra una
razionalità che mette in condizione che
tutti costoro di perseguire di mettere
in fila uno dopo l'altro i passi che
servono ad arrivare a portare a termine
la propria passione a compierla e quindi
la passione per l'innovazione possiamo
considerarla come una medaglia a due
facce la prima dionisiache estintiva ma
seguita immediatamente dalla seconda
faccia molto più illuministica e
razionalistica se dovessimo andare a
guardare sulla treccani per esempio la
passione è descritta come un sentimento
intenso e violento che può turbare
l'equilibrio psichico e le capacità di
discernimento e controllo beh nel nostro
caso a questo è immediatamente per
fortuna conseguente un momento più
razionale bene
ho provato a spingermi un po più in là e
quindi certo non con una ricerca
scientifica
però ho cercato di capire se ci fossero
altri elementi in grado di accomunare
tutte queste persone e devo dirvi che
con grande non dico stupore perché era
abbastanza attendibile però con grande
interesse ho scoperto che effettivamente
nella stragrande maggioranza dei casi in
tutti loro ci sono altri due elementi
importanti che sono la curiosità e la
generosità la curiosità è la curiosità
per capire per conoscere tutto quello
che non è il proprio campo quindi tutto
quello che succede perché succedono
determinate cose perché ci sono modelli
di business che funzionano in altri
campi e non nel loro e così via e la
generosità e quella è quell'elemento che
di fatto consente a ciascuno di loro di
mettere sul tavolo quello che sanno
quello che hanno capito quello che sono
arrivati a conoscere a disposizione
anche degli altri perché se tutti fanno
così dalla contaminazione di tutti
questi saperi di tutte queste conoscenze
per tutti nei propri campi
ne scaturisce qualche cosa di importante
qualcosa che i popoli può portare un pò
più avanti
e allora adesso è arrivato il momento di
spiegarvi che cos'è questo oggetto è
sempre per chi è in fondo lo faccio
rivedere anche le mie spalle
allora questo è una lampada una lampada
da esterni quindi immaginatevi una
lampada qua dentro e che diffonde la
luce attraverso il vetro
questo è un oggetto che ci è stato
portato da un imprenditore della zona
che produce lampade e ovviamente è che
ci ha sottoposto un problema ci ha detto
io utilizzo una colla per incollare
questo vetro a questo metallo che per
avere una precisa
aderenza assolutamente importante è che
io possa utilizzarla per venderla quindi
che non si sta chi ci mette 15 giorni
per me 15 giorni sono troppi perché esco
dal mercato i miei clienti tra il
momento in cui produco in cui incollo in
cui spedisco passa troppo tempo e
rischio di perdere i clienti
dateci una mano allora abbiamo
cominciato a lavorare con le università
con cui abbiamo rapporti siamo andati a
cercare il tutte le aziende che
producono a livello europeo collanti
abbiamo fatto ricerche su internet e non
riuscivamo a cavare un ragno dal buco di
fatto perché più o meno i tempi erano
sempre quelli
allora stavamo quasi per darci per
sconfitti e per andare dal nostro
imprenditore a dire no ma guarda scusami
ma non ce l'abbiamo fatta
quando andando a casa di un altro
imprenditore che fa cabine doccia ed è
leader mondiale nelle cabine doccia di
alta qualità andando con lui nel suo
stabilimento vediamo accanto ad una
parete delle lastre di vetro che poi
sono le porte della cabina doccia delle
lastre di vetro con applicati degli
inserti di metallo
allora la curiosità ci ha spinto
immediatamente a dire ma scusa ma questo
metallo tu come che lo colleghi come lo
appiccichi a questa porta di vetro dice
ma sì l'abbiamo utilizziamo un collante
standard a cui abbiamo chiesto dei
chimici con cui lavoriamo di fare una
piccola modifica quindi è un prodotto
diciamo un po esclusivo nostro bene ma è
quanto ci mette quanto tempo ci mette ad
accoppiare il metallo con con il vetro e
lui mi dice ma più o meno 15 20 e io
penso giorni non ci siamo e lui mi dice
secondi come secondi e allora a questo
punto e vi chiedo ma tu sei disponibile
a mettere a disposizione la tua
conoscenza il tuo know how quello che
hai inventato con questa colla con un
altro imprenditore che fa tutt'altro
quindi non è un tuo concorrente sei
disponibile a condividere la tua
conoscenza ovviamente sì i due
responsabili della produzione delle due
aziende stanno lavorando insieme questo
è un primo prototipo questo vetro è
stato incollato questo alluminio con le
caratteristiche che richiedeva il
produttore della lampada in tre minuti
ora tre minuti non sono quindici secondi
ma fanno la differenza rispetto a
quindici giorni
e allora questo è il momento in cui
effettivamente io ho capito ho compreso
che l'innovazione ha veramente due
sorelle che sono la curiosità e la
generosità senza le quali non è in grado
di creare valore di creare quel valore
che fa davvero la differenza quel valore
che è valore economico ovviamente ma
anche sociale ambientale e io sono
convinto che se francesco somaini fosse
qua oggi con noi sarebbe in grado di
darci un suggerimento è un consiglio che
è poi questo seguite sempre con passione
le vostre passioni
non spaventatevi e non vergognatevi di
sporcarle con un po di ragione
accompagnatele con tanta curiosità è
tanta generosità in maniera tale che
riuscirete a creare quel valore che farà
sì che potrete svegliarvi tutte le
mattine considerando vi fieri e
orgogliosi di quello che state facendo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]